You know, I am always getting ready
for home invasion or a situations mart.
It might be the problem is that they're
just too many things to worry about.
I can also,
I also have to worry about fucking ticks
and things that I can't see like flesh
eating bacteria and Murcia
worry about more than anything.
Leslie asteroidal impacts you
too. Yep. Oh really? Yeah.
Because they can come and then wipe out
civilization almost instantaneously.
There was something that I just retweeted
a yesterday of the Graham Hancock put
up. They found a new impact
site at 12,500 years ago,
that that coincides with
the end of the ice age.
This is one of the things that he and
Randall Carlson had been saying ad nauseum
and now Brian or Robert Schoch rather
who's a professor at Boston University.
Did you hear about the,
uh,
explosion on the media the
next December, December? Yeah.
This media that exploded in December
had something like 50 times the power in
the atmosphere. Oh, 10
10 atomic bombs. Jeez.
10 Times the power of the atomic bomb
that exploded in Hiroshima. Wow. Yeah.
And it exploded in our
atmosphere. But no, there's um,
this impact that they think happened
and well, there's two concepts. Uh,
Robert Schoch thinks that
it might've coincided.
These impacts might've coincided with,
uh,
he believes there's a great deal of
evidence for a mass coronal ejection that
there was some sort of a solar flare,
massive solar storm that happened,
which can periodically
happen every few thousand,
every few hundred years something can
happen. And when that does happen,
it just wipes out everything.
And he said that there was thunderstorms.
So like there's, they sit thunderstorms
or lightening storms that were like,
like the hail that was coming out
outside that we filmed today. But that,
but like lightening put that back up
please. Jesus. So this is the, uh,
impact created that they found in
Greenland. Um, it's say 30 miles,
31 kilometers across, which
is not 15 miles. Yeah.
Somewhere around 15 miles
in fucking sanely. Huge.
But do you think, um, as you
think about your impending doom,
which is going to happen,
right?
I just worry about the civilization
being we're so dependent upon electricity
and any small catastrophe, oh, this is,
they have an an impact
video of where it hit a wow,
so it's all, all this, this hit like
where there's glaciers right now,
but there's this massive
impact they got hit man. The,
the people that lived 12,500
years ago got hit. They got,
there's more than one crater too,
by the way.
This is one of the many craters that they
found during the time period of 12,500
BC or 12,500 years ago
rather to 10,000 years ago.
In that time period,
that 2000 year time period,
they think there was multiple
impacts on the earth. Why? Why?
I guess it just wasn't our time now.
Well,
we're lucky we've just been
through a really lucky stage,
but what he's saying essentially is
that this is what wiped out the Egyptian
civilization.
The first Egyptian civilization.
This is what wiped out the civilization
that built a, called Beckley tapping.
that preceded Sumir and ancient Babylon
and Mesopotamia,
that all those were a rebuild of a,
I can't wait for him to come back
on again. He's coming back on again.
Graham Hancock cause coming back on again,
I think April debate,
that other guy that you had on the
podcast, it was great. Yeah. Wolves,
Michael Shermer, who was actually a
friend of mine who I like, but he's,
he's a skeptic and there's an issue with
skeptics and that the issue is not that
it's not good to be skeptical.
It's very good to be skeptical.
The problem is when you
approach things as a skeptic,
you're not approaching
them as a scientist.
And I'm not saying that Michael Does this,
but that I think he did in that debate.
I think it was a mistake. People,
they approach these things looking
to debunk them rather than objective.
Really assessing all the possible
evidence. Right. And so because of that,
you miss out on big thing.
Like this is evidence.
This is not like big foot
tracks or some shit like that.
This is fucking real evidence of a crater
that they have dated back to 12,000,
500 years ago.
Yeah.
But people have a hard time believing
in doomsday scenarios because it kind of
like,
you know,
when you talk about taking the entire
chessboard and throw it in the air and you
have evidence for it, look at global
warming and stuff like that. There,
there is a,
I really believe that people have,
whether it's late and are not a religious
notion that we are ultimately sacred
and that God would never do something
that terrible to us on moss. And I really,
I really believe that like
humanity itself to go away. No,
because that would make no sense where
we're moving in a certain direction.
We're making progress. There's,
there's this sort of neural net,
it's becoming easier to understand what
it is to be each other, uh, you know, uh,
and, and that's kind of what virtual
reality and being able to download other
people's brains will eventually do.
That probably brings us into one,
I guess universal consciousness,
but you can go on and on.
So the idea that that would be all
obliterated before it happens before the
singularity, for example,
happens is too much to bear.
It would make no sense for us because we
have this narrative that we all kind of
adhere to.
It's very easy to do that.